-Welcome back, everyone.
We're hanging out
with Gwyneth Paltrow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
No, I know.
We love you.
We're talking about Goop,
but I also don't want
to glance over the fact
that you're a great actress,
too, and I love seeing you act
and so I love that
you're still doing both.
I do.
I do still love it.
But, I mean, are you now
leaning more towards
"I like being the CEO"?
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah, I think,
for the past number of years,
I've really leaned out of acting
and really leaned more
into my role at Goop.
And it would be impossible
to try to do both full-time.
There's no way and, as I said,
I love --
-It's impossible to do
most things that you've done.
-[ Laughs ]
-Really, it's true.
It's like the way
you raised your kids,
the way you dealt with,
you know, being a famous person
and then starting this
and all the, you know --
You just put the work in
and it's amazing,
what you've done.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Sweet.
-Is there anything --
-Oh, my gosh.
He's making me blush.
Is there anything [ Laughs ]
that you haven't done,
that you want to do,
you're like, "Well,
maybe I'll be a rapper"?
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I'd like to do ayahuasca.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-You mean job-wise?
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
-I'm not talking drugs.
Yeah, yeah, job, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about the detox.
This is the G.Tox here,
Goop G.Tox.
First of all,
I didn't know about this,
but what is a dry brush?
Can you explain this to me?
-Oh, my gosh, you don't know.
I wish I was there
because I would --
I would strip you
and dry brush you
[ Laughter ]
and you would love it.
-Wow!
That's the third time
someone said that to me
this week.
[ Laughter ]
What is a dry brush?
This is not a hairbrush.
-The dry brush comes
with the kit.
So this reset kit
is different than other kind of
detox programs.
It's really just like --
It's not super difficult,
like some detoxes,
which also have their purpose
you know, you just have
the sort of lemon water
for three days,
and they can be pretty brutal.
And this one has like
a clean food component to it
and we've got some amazing
protein powder
all developed
with our scientists in-house.
And it also comes
with a dry brush
because we also wanted
to sort of implement
the idea of self-care in it
and taking care of yourself
and dry brushing
is such an amazing way
to get your circulation going
and exfoliate
and it's an important part
of a lymphatic massage.
And so, with the dry brush,
really,
what you want to always do is
just like go long strokes
and towards your heart.
I start every morning
-Not in the shower?
-on my toes.
[ Laughter ]
You can do it before.
I do it either
before the shower,
if I'm going to hop
in the sauna,
or you can do it at night
before the bath.
I always like doing it
before like something hot,
but you can do it whenever.
-Does it wake you up?
-What?
What does it do?
-It just sort of --
I wish you could --
Can you expose some of your
flesh, so that you can...?
[ Laughter ]
Can you lift up your pant leg?
-No one wants to see that.
[ Laughter ]
You start where?
What do I do?
-So you start at your feet
and then you kind of
long strokes
up towards your heart.
It's always towards your heart,
so, if you're above your heart,
you kind of go
down towards your heart.
-[ Laughing ]
-And then, you always are
brushing towards the heart.
They say that it moves the blood
and it feels really good.
-How many detoxes
have you tried?
-Like every one
in the whole world.
-Right?
In your life, you have, right?
So you're speaking
from experience.
-I've tried, I think,
most detoxes and they're all --
I've never actually
had a bad experience.
Some taste better than others.
They serve different purposes.
And I know, you know,
your body actually, naturally,
has a whole
detoxification system,
but it just happens to be
that we're living at a time
where there's lots
of microplastics and stuff,
all kinds of things that are
harder for the body to detox.
So it's nice, once in a while,
to have like a period of time
where you give your digestion
a bit of a rest
and eat things that are really
easy to digest
and just let the body reset,
maybe lose a couple pounds,
if you want to.
But that's why
we created this one.
It's pretty comprehensive.
It's great.
It's got some amazing detox
powder for some liver support.
-You got cereal.
-Yeah, it's good.
-You have good recipes here.
What is a lymphatic massage?
-Lymphatic massage is like
a gentle massage
to help stimulate
the lymph to drain.
It's one of your important
detox pathways.
-Where would the lymph be?
[ Laughter ]
You have lymph nodes here.
You have them here,
under the armpits.
There's a whole system
of lymph in the body
and it's just like a gentle,
a gentle massage
that you can even do yourself
with just like a light pressing
to get the lymph to drain.
-So I just do this
and that's working?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just nice and light,
just nice and light and kind of
go down this way, yeah.
-I'm feeling something.
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty good, yep.
Now I'm feeling it.
Now I'm really feeling it.
[ Laughter ]
Pal, congrats on everything.
I'm so happy
when you come on the show.
-Thank you.
I really appreciate it
and I love you.
Gwyneth Paltrow, everybody.
-I love you, too.
Thank you so much.
-The G.Tox reset kit from Goop
[ Cheering and applause ]
is available now!